we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p troy york is not happy with
me because of my comments about Donald
Trump being a draft dodger
here is what Troy York had to say sure
you're listening to your comments about
Donald Trump his bone spurs and not
serving in the military let me ask you
David Pakman and your girlfriend rules
and you serve in the Argentine military
when you defend Argentina it bends away
Lenin David or how about Israel did you
serve in the Israeli army which many
young folks are required for two years
service to deal with the Palestinian dog
they must reside with well until they
ever conquer territory in the Middle
East I don't think you serving the
military mr. gaming angry so why are you
on Donald Trump's past hope for not
Saudi military and quietly
why should he serve in the military uh
okay it end up like a man like John
McCain right well a lot of offensive
stuff in this voicemail but the what a
number one no I didn't serve in the
Argentinian army because I was five when
I left Argentina and usually you don't
put five-year-olds in the army most
countries don't I don't know how they do
it in every country but most countries
don't have five-year-olds in the army
and I didn't serve in the Israeli army
because I was never a resident or
citizen of Israel and Troy York seems
fixated on me either going back to
Argentina or Israel a country I didn't I
didn't live there to begin with and now
that I serve in the militaries of these
countries why would I it doesn't make
any sense well it was Trump criticizing
Blumenthal's military history which he
himself dodged the draft and insert
right what is it out they do pointing
out that hypocrisy is irrelevant very
weird but always great to hear from Troy
York or Cecil booster or Luis Jimenez or
whatever his Latino persona is that he's
come up with over the years we've got a
great bonus show for you today don't
miss it david pakman.com slash
membership
it's tremendous you will love it that
folks I can guarantee